999 mila iscritti
ma che cazzo succede l a tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video sono fa
vj e molto probabilmente ho sputato
sulla webcam cazzo vabbè allora volevo
prendermi un attimino in forse sembra ha
detto un altro pro capite qualcosa
possiamo veramente ringraziarvi ma
ringraziare i ragazzi ormai diventato
banale nel senso che per una volta
ragazzi parlarvi faccia a faccia voglio
spegnere fa vj per circa un minuto poi
puoi ve lo restituisco duri per la prima
volta ragazzi voglio parlarvi da da
lorenzo perché lorenzo il mio nome ceo
io ho un nome nello specifico ragazzi
perché veramente alcuni credono che io
mi chiamo i favi j
non so come cazzo sia possibile ma va
bene quindi ragazzi questa è la prima
volta che faccio questa azione di mia
spontanea volontà
segnatevelo perché non lo farò mai più
ragazzi oggi per la prima volta solo per
voi il fa vigenti toglierà le cuffie e
sarà una cosa epocale
non faccio nomi ma giocatori
che cazzo è questo ragazzi questo è e
credo sia mio ciuffo ribelle ha deciso
di uscire fuori nel momento peggiore
però le ragazze accogliente anche qui
perché sono s'offende veramente ragazzi
abbiamo stiamo per raggiungere un
qualcosa di assurdo c'è io ragazzi non
lo so che ha scontato dire che non avrei
mai immaginato di raggiungere certi
traguardi lo so però veramente voglio
non solo ringraziarvi ma farvi vedere
che cosa siete stati in grado di fare
perché senza di voi non sarei qui perché
lo sapete già tutti quindi non c'è
bisogno che lo dica i ragazzi questo
traguardo perché mi fa i complimenti
perché veramente vi ringrazio perché mi
state facendo tutti ancor prima che io
l'abbia raggiunto però comunque la casa
io lo vuol dire che questo traguardo non
lo raggiungerò io soltanto lo dico
ancora prima di raggiungerlo non lo
raggiungo io ho solo io non è un mio
trofeo è un trofeo di tutti quanti noi
questa una cosa che dico sempre perché
ragazzi un canale non è formato da una
sola persona anche se sono soltanto io
che faccio i video non è non è questo
che forma un canale un canale formato da
diciamo una famiglia una magica famiglia
una riunione tra amici diciamo io di
amici evidentemente ne ho raccolti tanti
perché i ragazzi ognuno di voi lo vedo
come mio amico per questo che non non è
che vado in giro di mio caxxo io c'ho
999 mila iscritti porca [ __ ] sono un
figo noi o 999 mila amici ed è una cosa
molto più bella che avere 999 mila
iscritti così potessi abbraccerei ognuno
di voi però come ho già detto in passato
forse non mi ritroverei più le braccia
perché siete un po tanti e detto queste
ragazzine che posso concludere col
discorso né da lorenzo a 999 mila
persone posso ritornare ad essere
fatiscenti sempre scusatemi se ho preso
un attimino nel blog per dirvi questa
cosa però dovevo assolutamente dirvela
niente dire che possiamo tornare alle
nostre sembianze disumane
the messenger hotmail campli te che
cazzo è successo ragazzi ho perso
conoscenza per circa non so quanto tempo
ma direi che possiamo partire già dalla
formale della settimana che questa
settimana è stata vinta da enrico che ha
fatto sta guardando mi fa leggermente
cagare addosso però è [ __ ] quindi va
bene così
prima di cominciare ragazzine ripartire
con la user la prima chiuso volevo
assolutamente dirvelo perché devo
dirvelo volevo dire i ragazzi che tra
pochissimo andrà in vacanza perché
comunque da quando ho fatto gli esami
dal periodo all'esame io non ho
trasmesso la mente di far video avevo
diritto un pochettino al ritmo di dei
video quando ho fatto l'esame perché
ovviamente avevo l'esame però diciamo da
lì non mi sono più fermato siccome sono
anch'io un essere umano cosa che molti
di voi non pensano prologo sono al 2 che
altro ragazzi dal 12 al 19 che sono
all'incirca sette giorni più o meno
quindi ragazzi per circa una settimana
non succederà una volta l'anno adesso in
avanti però quella volta l'anno succede
perché essendo un essere umano vado
anche io in vacanza i ragazzi per una
settimana ne usciranno vido ma non sono
morto sono soltanto in vacanza come i
cristiani quindi entro questo però
ragazzi non vedo l'ora di ripartire
siccome stiamo per raggiungere un
traguardo pazzesco per quanto riguarda
gli speciali che arriveranno tra poco ho
detto specialino ragazzi perché tipo
alcune di voi se ne sono usciti dicendo
tipo mamima mescola già fatto qualsiasi
cosa fattibile nel mondo che mai milioni
di stringersi come ragazzi non posso
andare tipo sulla luna per fare uno
speciale di un milione di iscritti
perché ricordatevi che fa ho sempre
fatto video quasi tutti i video nella
mia camera per ragazzi ho trovato un
modo per riuscire ad andare in contro
tutti quanti perché invece di fare uno
speciale sono ragazzi farò ben tre
speciali per il milione di iscritti due
saranno completamente nuovi mai visti
non ho mai fatto cose del genere
mentre uno soltanto l'avete già visto ma
l'ho fatto soltanto una volta che è
piaciuto un casino e mi avete tutti
chiesto di farlo ciò che sapete tutti
qual è ma non ve lo dico perché sono
stronzo uscirà tra pochissimo mentre gli
altri due ragazzi usciranno il secondo
tra circa una settimana e mezzo più o
meno mentre gazzi per il terzo ancora
devo vedere con d'uscita perché è una
cosa un po lunga da fare ma vedremo poi
saranno delle cose epiche questo ve lo
garantisco comunque uscire
hanno tra poco tranquille e detto queste
ragazzine che con la hughes possiamo
chiudere possiamo passare allo scarto
dei pacchi perché è sempre un momento
profondo a sua volta ragazzi cerchio di
aprirne 3 siccome sono abbastanza grossi
tranne questo che dà la partiamo dal più
piccolo come al solito ma chi no vabbè
cos'è sto coso la virilità che emana sto
cappella è qualcosa di incredibile
ragazze che si si si si chiama certe
opere d'arte io non posso lasciarla in
disparte
questa è una poesia ci fa anche limite
tra tre questo il cappello se non so
quale dei due mi rende più figo però è
veramente fanno a gare poi cerchi che
agli d'affari e tible depp ma tutti gli
scrivo scrivo i nomi come po sopra e la
gente muore fantastico qualcosa ragazzi
che non mi torna perché ci sono i nomi
dei santi
quindi o questo è un death note bersanti
o è un calendario una delle due è bello
queste rinnovate epa è partito bene
perché c'è del polistirolo quando
ragazzi mettetele polistirolo
all'interno ci sono cose importanti tipo
tipo questo e soprattutto ragazzi anche
questo questa è la e la pinza fiocco che
non poteva veramente mancare me la metto
qui perché è [ __ ]
non capisco chi mi ha inviato sto pacco
voleva tipo trasformino una ballerina
però ci sta riuscendo
io non capisco soltanto il perché perché
non so se tipo un superpotere che io va
di mezzo alla strada e faccio tipo e
forse non mi investono e c'è anche tipo
questa che cazzo
ho capito che cosa fottutamente epica
ragazzi ho trovato un nuovo sport è
fantastico tipo passano all'ultimo
ragazzi ho sempre paura una roba si può
ma anche perché fateli riscatto l'anno
cos'è sei figo e non schiava forza 4
soggetto è un'araba guarda testo bambino
che ha una forza del tipo rotta tocco
l'ho vinto io vi ringrazio perché si
regali che mi hanno cambiato la vita
soprattutto le mani
detto questo ragazzi passano dalle forme
di sponda prima domanda arriva da span
span forse sarà addormentato sulla
tastiera trottole poi risponde con il
tuo più grande incubo allora da adesso
in avanti e questo cappello sicuro il
mio più grande incubo non lo so perché
sarebbe quello di rimanere tipo in mezzo
all'oceano non sotto km chilometri di
acqua che non sai che cazzo ci sono
probabilmente c'è voldemort
non lo so comunque è una cosa i miei
mimì non mi piace cioè non ci passerei
weekend wi fi che ne pensi di questo
[Musica]
ma messo sky l'opera quel modo in cui
sorride poi rispondere favi premi un po
di sole perché sei bianco come un
cadavere ragazzi verità sta roba del
bianco come un cadavere più che altro
colpa della quando quando faccio i video
c'è una luce che si accende di vento
tipo gas per però non è colpa mia e
della luce cioè la luce che mi toglie la
prosa va bene dai mano armata papi ti
sfido a camminare nella tua stanza per
10 secondi tenendo in equilibrio sulla
tua testa e dei pacchi cielo vicino
almeno ci ha provato per qualcosa come
mezz'ora a fare quella roba lì però
questo è stato il risultato migliore che
voi ci crediate o no coke e ragazzi
siccome devo mettere leggermente in
ordine ma vabbè quell altro discorso che
da te questo cappello mi sta uccidendo
dal caldo in una maniera incredibile
prova ben venti ragazzi servito è
piaciuto massa i calciatori come dove la
mia sedia mi ha preso un chip a chi
prendono un possesso della mia semi 6 il
video è piaciuto massa è tassato
commento mi piace anche a passare in
facebook che non e video trovato nella
descrizione serve se avresti destinate
quindi ci rivediamo il prossimo video
belle ragazze